normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government a
college friend of mine Wendy long
decided to run for the Senate I begged
her not to I told her that she was you
know would be would lose terribly but
she goes I want to do it so I go okay
I'll help you I gave her $10,000 which
is the campaign Finance limit but what
was happening is I'd put out a new film
on Obama I was traveling all over the
country and you know how it is with with
a friend of yours she's like oh denes
you know can you come and meet these
Indian doctors they're Indian you're
Indian you know we want to raise some
money here I'm like oh Wendy I'm in
Dallas you know so I felt bad so I told
two of my friends listen do you like
Wendy long give her $110,000 I'll
reimburse you so this is this was my
crime I exceeded the campaign Finance
law and look I did right so I should get
the same penalty as anybody else who did
that but normally that penalty is
nothing or at the most it's community
service a warning especially if it's the
first time offense the key to the
campaign Finance law is you're not doing
a quid pro quo like hey I'll give you
money but I want you to make make me a
judge then you're getting something
corrupt out of the deal this was not the
case here not even charged so that's was
what my case was about and the US
government would have liked to have
locked me up for more than as long as
they could but two years was the sort of
statutory maximum so they were going for
it they had a Clinton appointed judge I
mean the whole thing was like a show
trial who was your he made you get
re-educated bman in New York yeah oh in
New York York it was sdny the southern
district of New York so wow so it was it
was Eric Holder operating through an
Indian stooge whom I nicknamed Indian
Head waiter prit barara a guy who's uh
had a lot of notorious cases wow and so
on top of all this right so this is a
crime that as you mentioned people
normally will get community service for
or it's not prosecuted and not only do
they send you to prison they you
community service I'm sorry they have
you do re-education basically
re-education a big fine ex I mean when I
told people I had 5 years probation
there were guys in prison who were like
coyotes drug smugglers I mean people who
had in for rape and they were like like
I got two years you know they couldn't
believe it and they and I had great
difficulty you know one of the key
things about prison is like what are you
in for and part of the problem was I
felt like I might like make all these
enemies because none of them believed
what I would say they're like whose
money did you take I'm like no no no I
didn't take anybody's money I gave too
much of my own money they're like this
guy's lying we can't trust him what did
you how many how much time did you end
up so I was I was 8 months in an
overnight confinement Center so I was
free in the day but I checked in at 7:00
at night and I would check out at 7:00
in the morning and I slept in a dorm
with 70 paron criminals on a bunk bed
did you make friends uh I made some
acquaintances uh perhaps not friends um
but you know it's a window into our
Criminal Justice System it's a unique
experience for it's a very unique
experience although maybe not really a
lot of people are incarcerated yeah yeah
sorry I interrupted you Sheamus did you
yeah well no I just want to mention this
cuz what you said is it would have
helped you if people on the left would
have stood up for you you when you were
the victim of an obvious political
prosecution what's very sad today is
when people on the right are victims of
political prosecution people on the
right won't even stand up for them
gotten to that point prior to your your
case who was the who was politically
prosecuted before you I feel like you're
the first kind of high-profile one at
least since the turn of the century or
it was it was the first case but
interestingly at the time I saw it as a
one-off I mean I did not see it as a
Prelude to Carter page Papadopoulos
Roger Stone Michael Flynn Trump because
the way I saw it was okay uh I made a
movie on Obama it was emotionally
damaging because I went to the Obama
family Homestead I interviewed his
brother I kind of I made it kind of
personal and I'm like I know this guy's
a vindictive narcissist so it I should
have known there's going to be a big
Target on my back but I didn't see the
the institutional creep that has
occurred the escalation under Biden of
the police state is taken me by surprise
do you feel like you were sort of a test
case they were seeing how they could
test the law and apply it in this kind
of scenario yeah you know I thought my
case was a oneoff where Obama I mean and
this is funny cuz I go speak on campuses
right and people would be like I'd be
like I was targeted and then people go
what makes you think Obama watch your
stupid movie and I go I go well the
movie was in 2000 theaters and and when
the movie was reached the second most
successful political film ever made I
was being attacked every day on a
website called Barack obama.com so
that's kind of where I got the wacky
idea that maybe Obama and didn't like my
film
ex if somebody makes a a a film someone
makes a documentary Expos you explaining
all the things wrong with you you don't
have to see the movie to not like the
person like it's not like Obama would
have to sit down and be like I disagree
uh with this film like d that was bad
but people around him were like he said
this and he showed your family in this
light and that's all that's all you need
Obama went after the Tea Party corre the
IR started unjustly auditing them and
then we also know that Barack Obama
charged more people uh whistleblowers
and journalists under the Espionage Act
than all of the presidents combined they
call him Obama I I believe that Barack
Obama may be one of the worst Presidents
one of uh uh in my lifetime I think he's
the worst and a lot of people yeah oh
yeah yeah Joe Joe Joe may be heavily
influenced or or uh uh puppeted by Obama
but let me say this I know it's it's
it's kind of tough because you got you
got W bush you got Iraq you got
Afghanistan they just horrible things
and you have uh like Bush's attempt at
Presidential Directive 51 if you guys
are familiar with that but Barack Obama
has a I don't know like the National
Defense authorization authorization act
indefinite detention Provisions the
persecution of journalists the kill the
extrajudicial assassinations of American
citizens uh we have what he did to you
we have what he did to the uh uh um to
the tea party and you know honestly the
list goes on bombing civilian targets
hurricane Crossfire hurricane how about
Fast and Furious knew all about it fast
and furious sending guns to cartels is
the most protected man in American
history and uh part of it was the first
black president that gave him an
immediate sort of uh Halo and um and
he's also one of the most ruthless so um
I think and he's still around yeah and
and now he he he reflects a tendency
that's broad on the left because you can
tell whenever you're looking at stuff
that the leftists do they know that they
are above the law when Jamal Bowman
pulled the fire extinguisher he removed
the signs I bet it never crossed his
mind I'm going to be arrested I'm going
to be locked up it's going I'm going to
be held for 3 months he was probably
insulted when he got arrested yeah you
know who I am yeah or or or look at
those those protesters what was it in
which building was it the Canon building
I didn't see the slightest fear in their
eyes that they're going to come in here
drag us to the floor put us in solitary
they knew it was never going to happen
do you think Barack Obama is a leftist
or do you think he's a bad
liberal no I think that I think that
this is a guy and I've done a lot of
work on on on Obama I think this is a
guy who is is haunted by anti-colonial
demons uh that came from his father and
his father was a very intoxicating well
he was intoxicated he was drunk but he
was a he was also a very captivating
personality um a complete con artist uh
in Kenya for example he would frequently
show up at public events pretending to
be a minister of this a minister of
finance he'd be up on the podium giving
a speech when the real Minister of
Finance would walk in the door I mean
there's a comic aspect and then you have
him arrested he's Ste he's faking it I
see that in in Obama's brother I see
that in and Obama and he abandoned Obama
at Birth basically and and and
paradoxically Obama was obsessed with
the father he never had he goes down to
Kenya he goes to his father's grave he
has this kind of voodoo experience at
the grave it's all in my film by by the
way 2016 Obama's America um Obama's a
very interesting guy and I think part of
what put me on to him was I had been
seeing him through a civil rights lens
you know this is a guy his background is
like Montgomery Selma Martin Luther King
and that's how he was being portrayed
yeah and then when I read his
autobiography dreams from my father I
was like oh wow this is really more like
the India I grew up and all the Indian
intellectuals talking about
anti-colonialism and the British I'm
like this is the soil in which this guy
was cultivated so you think he's a
leftist then he is he is a leftist in
this you know we're talking about Hamas
decolonization Israel is the colonial
power little babies are settlers that's
Obama's ideology he's a smart guy he's a
smart guy you you can't underestimate I
mean the degree to which he has been
influential authoritarian the
authoritarian grasp and the things that
he's been able to do are shocking the ab
you have H you have Lisa Monaco who was
a longtime loyalist of his his his last
home Homeland Security adviser was Chief
of Staff to Robert Mueller and where is
she now she's the deputy attorney
general you have ail Haynes who also was
a top Deputy for Barack Obama and she is
now Joe Biden's Director of National
Intelligence and of course then you had
Susan Rice uh who was the domestic
policy adviser for a long time so he he
and he is the only President who is
remained in Washington DC and now we
know from reporting that you have Biden
administrated
Administration officials and Democrats
going to their mansion in calama and
meeting with him so he still is highly
influential uh in this Administration
and think over if Obama decided it is
important to me to move Biden out yeah
and kamla Harris out don't you think
that this would then become a top
priority for the Democratic party but do
you think that's why Biden is running
again because Obama ultimately wants him
to stay in office so can you have
control well I I don't think the DNC
wants Biden at all so we we have this
line I think it's one of the best lines
in police state where and it's Darren be
is talking and he says he goes in a
police state he goes you normally know
who's running it right who's running
China X who was running Cuba Castro who
was running the old Soviet Union Stalin
MH but our police state says Darren is a
little opaque Biden is in the canoe he's
obviously a willing accomplice but who's
steering the canoe we don't know I mean
this is a country right now being run in
my view by some kind of a hunter yeah
there are powerful people who are making
decisions Biden is cooperating with them
Obama may or may not be directing them
but I think it's the Obama ites it's the
Obama gang that's running it and in a
way Biden's very convenient because I
mean think about it you bring in a you
you know you bring in some strong willed
guy from California Gavin Newsome he's
going to want to run the show he's going
to want to give orders he's got a future
ahead of him he's got a future ahead of
him they Biden can't be the candidate he
can't be the nominee I mean there's this
really great clip we have from a Joe
Rogan uh experience with the rock where
The Rock Says look I got friends who
support Trump I got friends who support
Biden and then Joe goes you actually
have friends that support Joe Biden and
he goes no no no no no no no good good
check he's like that's that context
matters I have friends who support the
Democrats the reason that he they can't
have him though is because of the hit
because of the the gaffs that he's
likely to do that are going to likely
get worse not because they not because
he won't listen
or it's
because here's what I wonder that the
reason why they wanted Biden to be the
candidate in 2020 was because they
needed a sacrificial lamb whoever they
put in place had to reverse policies
Trump did that worked and made us feel
good and that's going to cause a lot of
hurt whoever does that is going to
suffer in the polls and in favorability
so we need someone who's not going to
run again all we need is your corporeal
for uh form Joe Biden that's what the
article said remember that one from the
Atlantic stay alive Joe Biden all we
need is your corporeal form I think
you're right but I still think that the
risk of having Joe Biden run again is
because of how because a failure on his
part a mistake an error shows that he's
not the guy running show yes well that's
what I was about to mention denes you
made this point about the US almost
being this strange kind of puppet state
where we don't actually know who's in
control behind the scenes and this is
something people always speculated might
be the case but then when Joe Biden came
long just became obvious that at least
in this Administration that definitely
has to be the case there's no way this
guy's making decisions he does not know
he's the president I'm sure he forgets
half the time more than half the time
man's completely out of it I mean he's
he's in steep cognitive decline it was
pretty clear that there were times when
Donald Trump would try to get something
done and the the you know the
bureaucracy itself would be working
against him and they admitted it and
they admitted it and I think with with
Joe Biden it is clear that whether or
not Joe Biden says the right thing the
the bureaucracy already knows what's
going to happen I mean he said it
himself they'll get in they'll get mad
at me if I say that what do they want me
to do he he speaks like that regularly
Julie what do you think about the
Biden's chances in 2024 I don't vot for
I don't think he's going anywhere and uh
if he wanted to there's no way that Dr
Jill will uh let him leave the white
house because she wants to stay first
lady more than I think she wants he
wants to be president you think that
she's no way what do you know
about and her her you know imaginations
of of towards power or whatever what do
you know she wants to be first lady she
wants to stay first lady she wants to
insulate that family which they are to a
degree obviously they are because
they're still in the white house uh I I
don't see any way to get him out of
there he's not going to leave
voluntarily uh unless you know he people
there's no way the way that the
Democrats with a straight face and
there's got to be a little part of them
that's a little sheepish in saying this
kind kind of stuff but I mean recently
you saw in MSNBC someone goes well
Biden's more articulate than any
functioning 45-year-old right I mean for
some sad for 45y old for someone to say
that with a straight face uh so with
with with Democrats they can count and
Federman is the same they can count on a
level of of media
rationalization media protection that is
just that will go to insane levels to
defend these people and I think they
have gone out of the way to present
themselves as like the best family they
could partially because they have so
much baggage looking at you Hunter uh I
me I mean they look back at Naomi
Biden's wedding that got her spread in
Vogue and the first picture you see is
her and you know her grandmother Jill
cuddled on the couch they are trying to
say we are this like ultimate American
family and we are restoring the White
House to this nice place and or I mean
but I mean look at the intellectual
jiujitsu where youve got a family Racket
and then they come out and go well I
mean this shows you that this man has
just an absolutely immeasurable love for
his kid even right boss this this Vogue
shoot that I'm referencing it's
interesting because it was like right
before Tiffany Trump's wedding at marago
but also Hunters nowhere to be seen in
it right the the bidens are basically
trying to pass themselves off as this
nice set of grandparents skip a
generation and then they've got all
these granddaughters forget the
grandsons you know what I mean like it's
a weird family and they ultimately do
these things to be palatable to the
American people to seem glamor and
desirable and to stay in the white house
so do you think Jill and Joe have kind
of like a bill Hillary thing going on
here where she's actually pulling the
strings and he's just the the face of
the organization cuz he's honestly not a
very good face right like Bill Clinton
has many flaws but he had some Charisma
so I could understand why someone like
her would attach herself to him in order
he was Maxim charismatic in the still
horrible back then still a horrible man
but but he was in
chargeing charge right Joe Joe sniffs
children con was very Charming I mean
that's how he got where he was for oh
that's where he got where he is always
seemed like in a Blow heart even when I
watch old CS of him he just seems like
aun never struck Charming he didn't yeah
in his younger days he had a he had a
frat boy quality by the way similar to
Clinton uh I think in the Clinton case
Hillary was sufficiently self-aware to
realize that she could not make it
across the Finish Line without bill M so
I think she signed up with Bill early on
she understood that this was a a bargain
because it was going to come with a lot
of baggage bill was going to do his own
thing but fillary was like that's okay
because I've got my eye on Power and in
the end if I become kind of Bill's
coverup man there are similar uh
conversations had about Jackie Kennedy
and JFK that she was aware of some of
his you know less desirable qualiity
specifically philandering and that she
chose chose anyways not to see political
office but to seek social capital and
power thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net